[Music]
this is the ramsay
show you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i am
best-selling author ramsay personality
rachel cruz and next to me and the
co-host chair
is dr john deloney today how are you
doing good how are you good awesome well
we're gonna get to the calls you guys
and give us yeah give us a call if you
have any questions about your life your
money
anything uh john and i are talking about
money and marriage a lot these days so
if you've got questions about
relationships and all of that let's just
dive in so you can give us a call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all right up next or up first i
should say is drew
from pittsburgh hey drew welcome to the
show
thank you so much
absolutely how can we help
so my question for you is in regards to
uh life insurance
yes and uh just to kind of lay out for
you the picture here
my wife and i got married last july we
have our first child on the way due in
may yeah and uh god willing we're hoping
for more children over the next 10 years
i'm 33 my wife is 30.
and
i right now i'm trying to get in the
position you know set up with life
insurance and just
kind of wondering the best on
how long i should get that for on based
upon i know you said it should be 10 to
12
times your annual salary and then uh
really until your your children are out
of the house uh so
looking to you know the fact that we'll
be having kids in the next 10 years then
would we be needing to get a 30-year
uh policy yeah it's a great question so
when it comes to life insurance so it's
either yeah when when someone is not
dependent upon your income anymore
or you become self-insured so where are
you guys at financially do you guys have
are you in debts what do you own a home
so we are
not in any debt we just bought a home so
we have a mortgage for 150 000. okay
but no debt that's awesome an emergency
fund and all that
correct yeah there's about 70 000 in the
bank oh that's great man yeah congrats
that's that's huge so what i would do is
i mean with life insurance and can
obviously the younger you are the
healthier you are the cheaper it's going
to be even with term life so um
so if i were you i would overshoot
probably what you need but you guys can
sit there and do the math and think okay
if we do baby steps four five and six
how long will it take us to pay off the
home
how long will it take us to build an
amount of money in in our investments
that we're comfortable with that if
something were to happen to you if you
were the only one bringing in an income
or if your wife works something happens
to her and look to see where do we feel
comfortable sitting if we had no life
insurance like if you have a paid for
house and you got two million dollars in
investments
pretty great right so so i would look
and kind of say okay in the next 20
years well what does our life look like
financially as much as you can and then
determine from there um
so i hope that helps true andrew i just
redid mine and for what it's worth i'm
taking myself through 60 and i hope that
um that and you're young enough that the
policy will be so inexpensive it'll
it'll still cost you money but it's
going to be so inexpensive to run you
through 60 years old yes and hopefully
by then if i become independently
wealthy at 50 i won't pay the last 10
years or i'll cancel the plan or
whatever and we'll call it good but
that's what i did in my house yeah and
when you can lock in the rates i mean
with term life which is great you that
that's what you're leaning toward that's
that's what we recommend uh because it
is so inexpensive to your point i'm like
you almost could just pay it and have a
policy on each other just in case you
know like mom and dad we always laugh
because dad still has life insurance on
him because mom wants it she's like i
don't care what we have i just want to
know that something happens to you
there's some extra cash coming just in
case so so yeah it's one of those things
that's inexpensive especially if you're
young and healthy that go ahead and just
yeah i would i would overshoot it if you
could it's a great questions room
all right next is nick from
philadelphia hey nick how are you
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
how can we help you
yeah so my wife and i are baby step two
i've been turned on to you guys for a
couple months now we've really kind of
gone crazy um
the big thing that we've done that's
made a huge difference is we finally
combined all our finances and got
totally on the same page financially
yeah and we should have done it years
ago
but hey but here you are i guess yeah
you're here now um
yeah so my question though um my wife
and i each own our own independent small
business
and we don't materially participate in
each other's business
how should we think about
like the spouse's input in a situation
like that
it's a great question why are you
laughing
because it's funny well because in my
house
i debate the amount of input i have like
on what we're getting at the grocery
store
let alone running a business just my
initial input nick is none
unless it's unless somebody asks you
right like you're the you're the ceo of
your business and
i i mean tell me if i'm wrong rachel but
i find the ceo of my business and you're
the ceo of your business and we're close
friends i mean if you ask me you're my
opinion on your business great sure but
i'm not gonna get involved there no but
i do think in a marriage there's obvious
strengths and weaknesses each person has
so like i would know if i was running a
business there are certain parts of
winston's brain that i would want to
know
yeah that i'm like no i want i i want
that thought or what would you do here
you know and vice versa so i think it's
um i mean i think the rule of thumb
always advice do you have a specific
thing in mind brother that happened well
what is no i mean nothing like there's
nothing like contentious going on but i
don't want to get to that situation ever
but one of the things that does come up
is like the concept of like business
expenses um like if i would want to buy
a new computer for the business or she
would want to do like advertising for
the business
how should we think of that um when we
could not
spend those things on the business and
you know pay down debt okay that's kind
of something i'm kind of struggling with
a little bit so i think it's important
that you two
with your business your business pays
you a salary
and that salary is what you take home
and you put into
the general pot
and if there's a
bottom line meaning you're just going to
take x percent of the of the overall
revenue of your business and that's what
your take home is going to be so not
buying a computer would actually provide
more money in your home that kind of
thing
i think that's a conversation you all
have it's a philosophical conversation
in a theoretical conversation
if you get into the weeds of each
other's business and you don't need that
i don't need this man that feels like a
recipe for disaster for me i'd rather
see you all pay each your business pay
your salary this is what we're going to
take home and then that's the money that
y'all are budgeting together
okay yeah that makes sense
and that gives like
some pretty you know that's the good
thing about numbers is like numbers
aren't emotional so so knowing okay yes
that's the number we've set for a salary
that's what's coming in that's the
boundary that's set so then if she goes
into her business and does pay more for
advertising or right or you go by the
new computer
that's within the business that's kind
of over that boundary so having that
hard number
makes i think a lot of this so much
easier i would love to see y'all have a
regular
um i don't know the right way to i don't
know what i would call this but it's not
a marriage retreat of some sort but
it's almost a business mastermind group
that y'all you're the only two members
and or maybe you invite some other
friends
and
you it's not for you to give advice but
it's for somebody to ask advice like you
mentioned i would love winston's brain
on some of these problems but i know
that if winston came in and just started
barking you know what you should be
doing
you can take that advice and walk out
the door with it right
so
wait to give advice until you're invited
into that conversation um but set up and
set up some pretty clear boundaries but
man cool if y'all talk to each other
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
ramsey personality rachel cruz here with
dr john dalone answering
your questions about life money
relationships and driving and try it
tell yes rachel i crashed my wife's
prius today we got us we got a story
that was a scary
it's scary and
why did you crash john i was not being
an attentive driver
mm-hmm
and you crashed i did i was doing this
i was doing some breathing exercises
which is not wise to do but yeah it was
not good man it was scary
and uh looks like we're gonna put the
old prius to bed dave's not gonna be
able to make fun of me anymore i'm gonna
have to get a new car
but we made it here okay do you think it
will be totaled oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah but you're able to drive no and no
one got hurt we'll say that was a single
car i just hit the that concrete divider
just so scary yeah it was pretty wild
going too fast not paying attention
i've my wife i'm i've changed america
i'm changing my driving habits effective
immediately
i'm gonna be a uh what do you call it a
uh speed limit driver oh i wasn't a
student driver nope not a chaperone in
the car
i'm going to be a speed limit driver i'm
going to drive a speed limit and just
slow down my life a little bit scary
that's a great
a great plan well
everyone's alive and well if you want
driving advice feel free to give us a
shout
that would be great if you're yeah
driver's ed teacher give us give us some
laws
driver's head teacher don't call this
show
oh but for real if you have a question
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five
two 225 all right up next is robert out
of phoenix hey robert how can we help
hey rachel hey dr john how are you guys
doing doing great
thanks so much all right so i have a
question uh i'm on baby step two right
now and
just recently i heard one of the
podcasts where um david said
you probably have too much car
and so the car is the last thing on my
debt snowball and i also owe more on it
than it's worth
so my question is should i just keep
blocking out the baby steps and pay off
the car as i get there
or should i try to save a little bit
like the negative equity that i have on
the car pay off the car and go get a
little beater to finish walking out the
step yeah great question how much do you
owe on it
i owe about 16 000 on it right now about
16 000. what's your household income
um i make about 70 grand a year okay and
what other debt do you have
that's it um student loans credit cards
um
i owe a lot to a t because i bought a
lot of devices because i was very
materialistic at the time yeah it's okay
we've all been there uh okay so what how
much does the rest does all that debt
add up to because you said it the rest
of it adds up to about 60 000 right 50
or 60.
60 60 but they're all small debts
because you said the car is the largest
correct
right i mean student loan would probably
be um my like second largest because
i've got like two or three student loans
and they're all like in the 12 or 13
range
okay so you have a total student loans
of 30 or 40 grand right
somewhere around there yeah okay yeah
well i would still recommend though
robert still doing that debt snowball
method even though yeah your student
loans they're they're all separate and
even though they add up to more than
your car still keep those separate
unless you want to consolidate those for
a lower interest rate you can do that
but
but again those quick wins and it's kind
of nice i mean a little bit that you do
kind of have these small chunks
uh because it's gonna help with the
momentum and the feeling like you're
that you're winning uh you're gonna get
those quick wins which is great so the
rule of thumb really with the car is
if like if you can't pay it off within
six months to a year
then you probably have too much car and
so you can wait until you get
to the point and take out a small loan
for the difference and then go get a
beater if you want to do that or if you
get to the point that the 16 000 is part
of that snowball toward the end
um that you get to there and say okay
what do i want to do you can make the
decision then uh but looking at this now
i mean
i don't think it's a make or break for
me honestly robert so i'd probably i'd
probably keep the car and just tell you
to get after it
um okay yeah because that's what i was
thinking like i wanted to think about
getting a beat over i'm like what about
the maintenance what about this what
about that i don't know i don't care
about that because
you're gonna live
you're gonna go gangbusters on this deal
and you're gonna be out of debt in two
years anyway
and you're not going to go to a
restaurant you're not going to hang out
everyone's going to laugh at you and
you're going to just smile the whole
time right and you're going to work two
jobs and three jobs so the time on this
deal the maintenance on that i don't i
don't care about that um i care more
about it's the math
like if you said that i have a 50 000
car we're gonna have a different
conversation yeah but the 16 000 yet to
the point that you're gonna be able to
pay that off in less than a year when
you get to that part of your debt
snowball um i think yeah what's the car
worth man uh it's worth about 10 right
now so i have like a negative equity of
about six thousand dollars on it yeah
because and then you'd go go take out a
ten thousand yeah you could take out ten
thousand alone yeah
yeah hope that helps robert thanks so
much for calling cars
they're the thing
i know you're either over you got too
much car you're crashing them into
things that's the theme is what it feels
like right now but it is amazing you
know the
obviously everyone wants a safe car
having a nice car is great because
you're in it a lot
but the utility of what a car does of
getting you to point a to point b tell
you what uh we've lost our minds i feel
like and we we laugh about it here and
obviously you know i i fall way over on
this side of it but
the car i crashed today was a 2010 and i
just put in the put a little bit of
money in it because i wanted to last me
another 10 years yes and because it's
it's a fine car it just gets me to and
from right i think when you just
disassociate yourself from the identity
like i'm the kind of guy that drives
this kind of car that's when you're just
a recipe for disaster right absolutely
and there is a real
uh sentiment about beaters and they're
gonna cost us
they often don't
take care of your car they often don't
a great honda
great toyota for eternity yeah forever
forever
all right up next is nick and birmingham
ham hey nick how are you
good rachel and john how are you doing
great how can we help
good um i have a question it's kind of
both a spiritual and a financial
question and so
a quick breakdown of me um i'm married
with two kids i have a two-year-old and
a five-year-old
i'm in baby steps four through six uh so
we've been attacking the house with
gazelle intensity uh and anticipate
paying off the house within the next two
years
awesome but i believe
uh absolutely but i believe that i um
have a calling from god to expand our
family through international adoption
um it's something that my wife and i
just recently uh started thinking
we've always wanted to have four kids
um
but i was uh baptized a few months ago
and it's been a crazy spiritual journey
over the past few months and um and i
think god has waited on our hearts to
look into international adoption so i
guess my question uh the first thing is
i know nothing about
the adoption process and we've we've
talked to some people here and there
over the past week or so
um but also financially obviously it's
not
uh the cheapest thing in the world um so
i guess given my situation um
where i'm at in the baby steps
only having the house
left to pay off um how do i kind of just
approach that um financially and prepare
for that if that's something we
ultimately want to pursue
well all great questions nick and i
think the the heart of adoption i think
it's one of the most beautiful things um
for our family to do and
um yeah so for you guys i mean you are
you're in a position to do it i mean you
guys don't have you don't have debt you
don't payments you're able to take your
income if you guys wanted to
um
and put a lot towards it versus
attacking the house with gazelle
intensity so you could even pull back
from that some if you wanted to um but i
know that there's
tons of you know agencies out there and
people that really can walk beside you
in this process because there's a lot of
layers to this and there's a actually a
great book called adopt without debt
by julie gum and she walks through her
entire story how she did adoption
completely debt-free
and so that can just give you some ideas
and a starting point
to be able to start this journey because
it can be done debt-free and
and again this book is it's a great
resource i recommend everybody who's
going on this sort of major life change
journey they feel like they have a
calling get a couple of people in your
life who are down the road 10 15 years
who have been through the international
adoption process take them out to coffee
make them a regular part of your life
and learn what's actually going on
don't mistake a calling for being
irresponsible
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
well in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt free stage we have shelby and
probably one of the best names i've ever
heard maximilian thank you thank you yes
from detroit my parents named me john
and your parents named you maximilian
that's incredible i'm gonna thank my mom
for that one my dad who wanted to call
me teddy so
dude not even short into max like the
full thing yeah it's awesome okay well i
love it we're here to celebrate you guys
because
you've done what some would say is the
impossible but you are debt free
so tell us your story when did this
start
um it started about a month before we
got married my aunt sarah had mentioned
this dave ramsey guy after i was
complaining about how the numbers on my
student loan payments weren't going down
and then we were doing pre-marital
counseling and i was talking to pastor
daniel wein williams lake church um
about that and he was like well you know
we got a guy here at the church who
teaches the fpu classes so
we signed up and
and we just did it and did it together
before you're married so how much did
you guys pay off just under 43 thousand
dollars awesome making what kind of
money we made between seventy and eighty
um during the two years that's awesome
and how long did it take you two years
and three months two years and three
months you'll do for a living
uh i'm a freight broker so a freight
broker a freight broker okay i thought
you said something else yeah yep
and um i work for the family business
doing lawn care and some construction
projects with my dad that's awesome yeah
it's great okay so
two years ago you guys are engaged you
got how long have you guys been married
now at this point
um
three years
three years 2019 we got married together
10 years though yes okay yeah it's all
running together maximilian you should
have that number in your back pocket at
all times 11 11 coming up yeah
yep so what was it for you guys that
clicked you guys went through financial
peace university and what was about it
that you thought okay we're going to
change stuff we're going to change the
way we've been looking at money handling
money and we'll start paying off this
debt
yeah i think um
for me because the majority of the debt
was my student loans i just got mad at
looking at the number and i wanted to do
something about it and um
you know it's great to have a husband
who is so supportive and on board he
he's very willing to do almost like
anything i ask of him so i didn't really
have to like persuade him into it so
that was nice she's kind of here for the
ride you know yeah
aren't we all man yeah
so
yeah i don't know i think i just got mad
enough and i just like the more i
started learning about the ramsey
program it just it made me even more mad
and we just originally we tried to we
were thinking we'd do it in three years
and even when we made that goal we were
like
i don't know we can do that yeah but
we'll just
we'll just see how it goes and then as
we started going and getting closer it's
like you learn how to cut out the little
things and that makes even more of a
difference so then we made our new goal
to get debt free before our daughter's
first birthday and we did that beat that
by like a week so so when you said you
were getting mad we're getting mad at
so i was told by like friends and family
you know like if you can put a
extra money towards your your payments
you'll be out of debt faster and blah
blah so i would put like 25 50 bucks
extra towards my payment and after like
a year of pain i was like i'm gonna see
what my totals at and it had increased
like from the original start of what i
was paying and i was like you've got to
be kidding me how is anybody supposed to
get out of debt this makes no sense and
you know when you go to college they
tell you you're going to get a job and
yeah don't worry about the student loans
you'll be able to pay those off real
quick because you're going to have a big
girl job and
like unless you're intentional and you
make those big sacrifices like the
number doesn't go anywhere yeah so
yeah it's
maximilian what was it like
dating somebody that you've fallen in
love with you already spend your life
with her and then she's like by the way
i'm coming in with a cool 50 grand in
debt yeah you know
it's kind of accepted because we both
went to the same college
i guess you just kind of accepted that
like that's normal
when she told me about this program
uh i was you know like i said in for the
ride wasn't sure what it was gonna bring
but i think with her type of personality
she's so
uh
you know persistent and disciplined like
she's very headstrong as soon as she
wants to do something she'll go out of
full throttle and seeing these payments
she's done by herself
i mean i think i saw
it was seven payments just back to back
even when it wasn't pay week she was
still putting money in and i was like
okay this is serious like she's she's
putting
some serious control on her debt and and
lowering it and i think that's where i
was like okay this is why i want to
pitch in i want to help out i want to be
a part of this
it was inspiring and motivating too
awesome it's amazing when a married
couple does that right you work together
and it makes it go that much faster i
think that's part of the magic of you
guys paying it off a year earlier than
you even were expecting which is amazing
yeah so who were your biggest
cheerleaders during this time we had a
lot of supporters but i'd say the
biggest is probably um my parents darren
and lisa and then as well as my
grandparents um aunt sarah and uncle rob
our fpu coordinator bud who came to
support us today with his wife
um and a fun teaser for the next hour of
the show though there's another debt
free screen that you guys are aware of
oh yeah and who is that my beautiful
parents darren and lisa they're going to
be on and they've paid off their debt
too it's like the family affair i love
it it's great we're so excited to be
able to do this uh together you know max
was easy to get on board but um
my parents they were a little trickier
but like you said i did assistant so
i eventually got them on i love it well
you guys you've done a fabulous job so
how does it feel how does it feel
it's crazy it's like you you kind of
imagine what it's going to feel like but
it's better than what you think and it's
just crazy in a culture where like debt
is so accepted like once you're
debt-free you're like that was so dumb
like never again yeah no
you know we got friends getting houses
with nothing down and brand new cars
they can't afford and all this stuff and
we're just like oh that's good yeah
congrats absolutely behind closed doors
are like never not us
no because you tasted the freedom you
know what it is it is it's freedom and
then it's it's crazy too because you
think when you're debt-free like oh i
have this
much more money to spend but now it's
like man we don't even really want to
spend it we want to save it and you know
now we have other goals so
yeah sweet little avery yeah we were
joking about uh now that we finally paid
it off it's like we want to go back into
debt just to do it again
once you build momentum and see that
number grow oh it was it became a game
it was just fun hey the game's fun when
you flip it around and yeah wealth
building right yeah yeah yeah we're
getting there
and giving it all away is fun too yeah
yeah it is for sure congratulations i
know absolutely do you want to grab
avery or she go ahead right now yeah
she'll probably stop crying when she
sees me no that's perfect all right come
here babe so we got shelby maximilian
and sweet avery who's about to be one
two two two i'm sorry about to be two
going again and they've paid off almost
close to 43 000
making 70 to 80 000 in two years
count it down let's hear your debt free
screen
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
oh amazing absolutely amazing and we've
got a copy for you guys baby steps
millionaires
and the total money makeover to pass to
friends and of course babysits
millionaires is the next part of your
journey
i love it i love when the babes are in
the little
babies is my favorite it's my favorite
because man it's possible i'm like this
couple has been married three years
sacrifice everything
put all their effort in and now that
little one's life is is forever changed
completely different and
they've proven to themselves as a young
married couple from
us two or old married couples now um
that not if but when things show up in
our lives which they will right that's
just part of doing life is doing hard
stuff together
they know they can come together
develop a plan and that they're going to
follow it and man
max they don't make a lot of husbands
like max who looks at his wife and says
i'm going to walk lockstep with you i'm
not only going to walk in front of you
and behind him and walk next to you
we're gonna do this thing together yeah
and that's that's just incredible man
what a gift there is there's such a a
power
a power that happens in a couple's life
when they do this right when you have
anything in your life that you think
doesn't be hard yeah but we're doing it
together like we want this instant
gratification in life right we want that
but it's the journey that forms and
molds you so much and walking through
that together and choosing that
sacrifice it does i mean it changes your
marriage forever because like you said
they can do anything now absolutely
anything absolutely and all you guys
listening
you can do this you can do anything
just as they've proven today this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
back to the ramsay show i am ramsay
personality rachel cruz alongside me dr
john deloney hosting today
so we're gonna get to scott in
indianapolis hey scott welcome to the
show hey rachel hey john um john sorry
about your accident uh it's like bummer
but i'm glad you're okay thanks man it's
my don't fault that's what i get
it's what i get probably probably trying
to wake you up for something so pay
attention thanks man
my wife said the same thing scott you're
not helping
well no i meant in the bigger scheme of
things
so what's up man well um
i just really want to
like express my gratitude for your
ministry because uh my wife and i are in
a position where we really have a
tremendous peace about where we are
financially and and that's do a lot to
your ministry so thanks very much for
that well you guys did it you guys did
it
well we are in a position now where
we've got some financial stuff coming up
and i wondered about sort of a strategic
shift um we've been focused a lot on
like college savings and
um and paying the house off and you know
those types of things but uh we feel
like we're really heavy in retirement
and we have um you know two vehicles
that are probably like i call in the
zone meaning anything could happen at
any moment you know with uh with both
cars so yes um but we're not ready to go
out and buy a new one but just to
prepare for that and also um
my wife has a special needs brother he's
an adult that we would likely have to
care for and we just can't do that in
the house that we're in now so
just some things that might be on the
horizon here and i'm wondering if
shifting away from
retirement savings and
some of the other type of thing might be
an option to prepare for those
potential expenses um because we feel
like we're really heavy in retirement
are you guys doing more than the 15
we have in the past uh we're not right
now we're probably right there at 15
so
my recommendation scott would be that
yeah i mean the car situation you know
is more obviously more urgent and going
to be more recent than the house
situation so are you thinking with the
home are you guys going to move homes
completely or you have to refurbish and
redesign your current home we are pretty
tight here just with land and things
like that so we would um and we probably
just
we have three little boys so having a
separate living space like either either
a carriage house or like an apartment
above a garage or something like that
that would let us have some independent
space absolutely still care for him and
he's high functioning and
and not you know
and
a great guy just just had some um
disabilities yeah absolutely well it's
very kind of you guys to um to step in
there for him in his life so
i love that so if i were you i would not
go over i would not go under that 15
percent i want to keep that steady
because the thing with investing
specifically is you know even if you
guys paused it for four to five years
like going backwards you can't refund
your iras your 401ks
these retirement funds in the past you
just can't and so can being consistent
in that at 15
um is something that i would i would
encourage you to still do
uh kids college you guys could look at
saying hey let's slow down on that just
a little bit maybe
maybe slow down on the house for just
you know a few months and and to save up
cash again for the cars that's what i'm
looking at first and foremost yeah um
and then this is enough on college like
where do you kind of say hey we've got
that covered
i would talk to a smart investor pro and
they're going to be able to kind of do
the math especially if you have little
ones that hey in 18
years here's what it's going to look
like if it's invested in a mutual fund
or whatever the 529's in or the esa
to be able to do that math and the thing
about college too you know i always say
when you get to this point this is a
gift for your kids that you're able to
help with college um but also there's a
lot of kids that go to college debt-free
that never had their parents help but
but setting people up to do that is is a
gift and taking care of your family in
that way i think is is a great thing i
think it's important that you and your
wife just
the the scenarios you laid are rather
amorphous
they are are hey we want to kind of stop
doing this so we can kind of start doing
that
i would get real specific and you've
heard me say this a thousand times i
know that sounds like a broken record
but this is one of those moments in your
marriage you got three young kids
where
you're going to clear the deck
and the challenge a lot of folks run
into when you're in this situation is
they want to keep living as things were
but y'all's life is different now
right and so let's have a half day
retreat with just you and your wife
let's go somewhere let's get out of town
let's get somebody to watch the kids and
let's say okay
where are we we have three little ones
how old are they
uh six is our youngest and we have an 11
year old and a 13 year old so they're
all boys yeah you've got stinky hairy
boys now you got a six year you know i
mean like our life suddenly shifted and
all of a sudden we blinked and we've got
a teenager now and we've got a
six-year-old who still doesn't know what
day it is and let's get out and say okay
here's our life here's how much money we
have here's how much we've paid down our
house
what would a house look like where do we
want to move what we want to be doing
and let's get real specific about these
goals that you want and then yeah hang
on to your retirement principle i love
that rachel because that's the one
that's going to hang on you and if you
want to move move and if you want to
pause on the on the student loans thing
i i mean with this
paying for college i've heard people say
i just wanna have fifty thousand dollars
a kid i wanna have a hundred thousand
dollars a kid because of my job and this
i'm gonna be put two hundred thousand
dollars away for each kid i think that's
a very personal thing and never lose
sight of what rachel said it's a gift
there's not a
an ethical mandate or a spiritual
mandate or a governmental mandate that
you come up with 100 of wherever your
kid wants to go to cut right so what
number can y'all afford right now and
you got a brother moving in with you and
y'all are of a great spirit and a great
heart and so i say that's a right now
expense that y'all need to start
preparing for because you know it's
coming so again let's get real specific
about what we're gonna do and be real
specific about what we're not going to
do and that clears a lot of this this
ambiguity up right no absolutely that's
i think that was what i was going to say
next to which is perfect so i'm like put
numbers to it right when you're able to
put numbers into know an actual plan um
we have a guy that we work with in
marketing here at the office and he
always says like um you know you you
have to be able to just see it actually
you say this too but but the picture yes
that thing and and so even just pulling
up the picture like literally finding
something there here's the kind of car
we want here's an ideal house what is
this going to cost i mean all of that
giving any level of of weight to these
options um in a sense of just reality
not that they're just kind of floating
in your head and you think you might i
don't know
and go kelly blue book your current car
see okay if they're about to if they're
about to die out maybe you sell them now
put any extra cash you guys have and buy
new ones in the next month or two i
don't know so let's talk about that real
quick um
often couples and we've said this before
you know they we all do we speak in
words but we think in pictures and so
you and your wife can be talking about
um you know we need to get new cars
well
my mind flashed another 2010 prius your
miner
flashed a tesla right and so we're going
to decide like we're going to go past
each other with what we are looking for
and what our dreams and goals are we
need to get a new house
she may be thinking of 4 500 square foot
house and you're thinking a 2800 square
foot house and so
the difference there is 500 000 right
right and so let's get very specific
this house this car this time this place
and then you can have some values
conversations and some telling the truth
conversations i don't need that you
don't need that and then we can land on
a path and once you get that path man
then it's you're off to the races that's
what it is yeah
and so with this whole i love that when
you say this about you know we speak in
words we think we think in pictures
what can couples do out there that are
like man i'm just missing my spouse and
x y and z it could be on anything right
whether it's um
goals or you're wanting to change career
anything like how can people put that
into
practice today
the key word there is practice and is to
take the pressure off we build up so
much pressure on each other and we just
miss each other and then it's like we
lost the super bowl you didn't man you
dropped a pass in practice that's we're
practicing right and so instead of when
you find yourself using that ambiguous
language like i should just clean up
around here
be specific what does that mean because
for me that means i'm gonna put my shoes
away for my wife that means i want you
to spray and wipe down all the counters
and make sure all the stuff's in the
dishwasher right
and again i'd love to be able to to
honor her in that way and to take care
of the house in that way and be a great
partner in the house i didn't even know
that was a thing right yes um and i
remember talking to my son once and he
was six or seven and he was
we were in so in a public space and he
was saying something and i said will you
just be cool man and my wife said what
does that even mean i thought
how do i
i gotta paint a picture for my
six-year-old we need to do that with our
spouses we do that with our friends we
do that with our workplaces and be
really clear i love it love it
well thanks america for tuning in and
thanks to james and jenna in the booth
for helping us out this hour this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsey show where america hangs out
to have a conversation about your
relationships your money your life just
about everything the advice is free and
worth just about what you pay for it
give us a shout triple eight eight two
five five two two five i'm john delony
joined here by the wonderful
best-selling author brilliant rachel
cruz and we are taking your calls on
just about everything everything how are
you live doing great yeah doing great we
have a big thing going on tonight i know
yeah if you're listening live tonight
it's gonna be a fun night yes so
marriages all across the country
we know this hey lockdown's over uh
lockdown's back and then it's like oh
okay finally lockdown's over school's
back
marriages across the country could use a
date night right now we are on the eve
of the eve of the eve of valentine's day
an evening to come together and focus on
what matters most connection and
communication
some of the challenges the last few
years have pulled you closer together
maybe apart whatever it is
we can help you come together tonight at
special valentine's edition of money and
marriage with me and rachel cruz
streaming directly into your home at 7
p.m we're going to walk you through life
we're going to have fun we're going to
talk about sex we're going to talk about
intimacy we're going to talk about money
we're talking about fears we talk about
everything goals
all the things yep it when it comes to
peeves right so everything go to
ramseysolutions.com
events to get your ticket the 30 bucks
it's the cheapest ticket date night you
can have and will help your marriage and
relationships get better speaking of pet
peeves give me one what is your biggest
pet peeve about your husband how about
winston and i love your husband he's so
great i know i can't imagine he has any
wednesday i'll say this i don't know if
it's him or if it's me i'm a little bit
late but i'm just laid back i don't have
many things and i'm like oh gosh oh gosh
but he does a protein shake every
morning uh oh and he leaves it just on
the counter
so you see it and i just see it i'm like
we can we can just do two more steps
and two but here's the problem if you go
on my nightstand i have like 18 cups of
coffee yup sitting there too so um
that's my thing these cups everywhere my
uh
i have a thing about using an old cup
or i just forget yes i was we have a gym
downstairs in our house and i just i
don't know it's like these moments your
eyes open and i just think why why are
there 11 cups
i texted him for the show i was like hey
if we're going to talk pet peeves what's
my what's your base my feet about me he
said granola bars in the cup holders
number one because i always eat granola
bars in the car and i always just
put in the cup holder he took a dive on
that one he's got some way worse ones oh
i'm sure but i'm me but i'm like i'm the
messier one i would say
like i can have stuff places and it
doesn't like bother me i mean it's like
for him and i'll say the way you just
said i'm totally laid back i just don't
know why he can't take two extra steps
to put the protein thing my guess is
you're super laid back super laid back
super laid back until you're not and i
bet it's incredible
i know it's tough okay what's sheila's
for you you think i mean she doesn't i'm
i mean i'm
i don't i don't say i'm perfect but i'm
pretty close super close to perfection
the man her laundry list is pretty long
i'm late to everything that's a huge pet
peeve um
i i think
the room is close enough
and she thinks things should go where
they belong or in the hamper or things
like that i think the room is fine um
and you know i saw that speech that that
guy gave about making your bed in the
morning for the first win of the day or
whatever i think that's great and i love
that idea
man never i never we never make our best
really
never it's it will change your life
it it makes everything better i don't
believe because my life's pretty great
right now you know
you don't yeah
you don't know the other side of the the
equation here the other variable you
should try it just as a n equals one
experiment your life will be better but
here's the thing if you don't do it and
your spouse does winston does sheila
looks at me
with this just
shame and disdain kind of like you were
talking about like
it's not i mean it's like four pieces of
cloth you can just pull them tight and
the whole thing's over and you can't do
that and so then i feel small and
sadness anyway uh and yes i leave my
protein shakes all over the place too
all of it i know it happens but hey it's
marriage right it's marriage and y'all
are what 20 years
yeah we'll celebrate 20 years this year
20 years wednesday what month
anniversary july oh a great month yeah
it's good i agree it's a great month
great month is that y'all's due no
december opposite month that's a
terrible month all right let's go to
john in manhattan what's up john y'all
been having a boring year what's up john
i want to know what you're
are you are you married john
hey john are you married very much so
nice five years okay what's the bit
what's your biggest pet peeve about your
wife
i was hoping you'd ask me that the
biggest pet peeve is that she's just
always right
she's already got the answer
well thought out before i even come to
the conclusion hey john is she's
standing right behind you with the
weapon point like if you need help
brother i'll call you
are you in danger are you a danger
all right hey what's up man how can we
help
all right so my wife and i have a very
unique uh situation here so we're 33 32
years old we are on the last baby step
as far as i know
we have a
mortgage 300 000 550 is the value of the
house she's in school right now for a
nurse practitioner after the last two
years with cash flow for college
now we had twins unexpectedly so three
months ago
yep yep nice very nice surprise
um the house that we bought those a
starter house you know it's a three
bedroom two bath it's a ranch fifteen
hundred square feet there's only so much
space you have here and we also have a
toddler who's three years old so working
from home remotely clovid you know
you're getting on top of each other we
need to expand now we need to sort of uh
flap our wings i guess get get more room
but the housing market over here is just
insane you know you look for something
that's like a four bedroom five bedroom
you're talking about maybe eight hundred
thousand
and i have a fifteen year currently and
it's within twenty five percent so on
and so forth so we'll start between like
a rock and a hard place what do we do do
we buy a house right that needs to be
fixed up because everything on the
market as far as we see is uh you know
needs a gut job is what we call it
or do we expand and if we do spend and
we like our location like where we are
how do we pay for it do we
do we you know take out equity out of
the house do we try to cancel something
like that so we just need a little bit
of direction uh as far as what to do in
terms of i guess living situation here
yeah it's tough and i feel like in in
really high real estate markets parts of
the country whether it's california
florida manhattan new york you know all
of that it yeah not compared to those
places i feel like there's like the like
it's just the insane and we always kind
of laugh because we're like
but you're not excluded from math right
like just because you live in manhattan
like the math still it's still a thing
so
so so just on that side of the equation
john i mean
looking to say okay what can you afford
like are you guys would you guys be able
to still be within that
15-year fixed rate 25
by moving out even maybe a little bit
further since you guys are working from
home
is there any part of you that says okay
let's go out 30 more minutes um you know
to to get out of manhattan
proper if there's any way to to be able
to expand and go out a little bit
further
you're technically speaking i'm in the
burbs okay so you don't have like an
hour and a half give or take
so i
i'm with you rachel i
here's the hard thing john is the the
math works and this is where
these are hard conversations but is this
the place we're gonna live and if this
is the place we're gonna live this is
the place we can afford in this place
and i'm gonna make peace with that place
if you're already in an hour and a half
commute every day brother and you're
already in the burbs and y'all are
coming in and out
and i think it's a hard conversation
about what would life look somewhere
else if we want to expand if we want to
expand or stay where you are or cash
flow the expansion
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me 130 000 all
thanks to what i learned at bethel tech
you could be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show give us a shout
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm john delony joined here by
rachel cruz and we're taking your calls
on just about everything money life
retirement marriage
all of it let's go out to gabriel in
columbus ohio what's up gabriel
hi rachel hi uh dr john thank you for
taking my call you got it what's up are
you married gabriel i'm gonna jump in
and out
no no i'm not are you dating anybody
uh i am dating yes oh
okay we need a pet peeve what's your pet
peeve um i think i think when she comes
over she like goes to close the cabinets
in the drawers really hard that i find
like a silverware kind of tray kind of
pushed all the way back and so
i think that
gabe she's got some rays some aggression
some aggression of opening the drawers
she's got some rage yeah that's rachel
she's like no everything's fine
no but i'm aggressive when i like put
things away so i could see like things
are being flung around okay i love it
love it what would you say her pet peeve
is about you gabriel
um i think i i tend to leave my clothes
all over the place too um so i think
maybe that it's disgusting and
ridiculous okay we're just kidding i do
the same thing same thing all right
brother so what's up how can we help
so i actually i actually have a
relationship question um and so that's
my question then maybe i could you know
you guys can ask me um additional stuff
but uh so i'm struggling with like
trying to figure out if if she's willing
to
get as serious as i i
am to get out of debt and so i
want to know kind of kind of like how do
i navigate this so that the relationship
you know if the relationship takes a
state a step forward we are a couple
that are on the same page about money
and or could this be like a red flag
into like future money marriage issues
hmm how long have you all been dating
um three and a half years
so you know her pretty well why won't
she get why doesn't she have any
interest in paying off her debt
um i mean when we talk about money you
know i bring up my intentionality and i
i recently signed up for fbu so i'm
starting to do that but uh when i talk
to her about you know like the steps and
stuff like that she doesn't seem
interested um she does say yeah i
obviously don't want my student loans
you know hanging around me forever
uh but she also like has a savings that
she kind of um fears of training uh down
to kind of pay her student loan debts
and she recently got a new car that was
signed by her dad
so i kind of feel like i don't want to
bring all that on if
um she's not willing to be on the same
page
almost all of the time
getting on the same page about a thing
with your
romantic partner with your girlfriend
your spouse whatever
is not about the thing
it's about
uh communication it is about us painting
a vision for one another and we are
leaning into this so to answer your
original question
um this is rarely a money issue
it's usually a vision issue
um
what i've seen in a couple years rachel
you do this way longer me what i see is
often and again i'm gonna unnecessarily
gender this but
guys get a hold of this plan and they go
at their wives or girlfriends and they
give them a bunch of tactics here's what
you need to be doing this and this and
this and this and this
i mean the natural response to that is
no i'm not doing that
it's different when you sit down and say
i am scared and i feel out of control
that i owe this much money and for our
future what i would love for us to be
able to do is to sleep at night i'd love
us to
be able to focus on building wealth and
changing our family tree and providing
our kids a home
where they are safe financially where
they don't have to worry about college
where we're not going to worry about
shoes and food it you see what i'm doing
i'm painting a picture in a vision and
if you can get your partner to join that
vision with you then you reverse
engineer that vision and say okay what
are the steps it's going to take to get
here and what you've got that
millions and millions of other people
have had is you're taking fpu now you've
got a plan that works 100 of the time
and i but i have to get you a part of
that vision does that make sense
yes yeah it does make sense and i would
say 2k real she's never um from what it
sounds like
she doesn't have urgency in it because
she didn't have urgency i mean her dad
signed a note with her um she has
student loans that everyone else has and
it's fine so there's a there's a level
that she has to come to to say she
doesn't want it for herself like she has
to be able to say
i don't want
this i don't want to live like this
because it i mean there's a
truth that right that she could
sacrifice for you and say i will do this
for you and all of that
but it's something about getting her on
board to that vision that john's talking
about that's that's really crucial and
so i think asking her questions of hey
what do you want life to look like or
hey if we're on opposite pages is that
okay with you like i wonder where she's
standing with all of this because
honestly as uncomfortable as she's
making you
you may make her that uncomfortable with
being you know down this plan that is
weird and saying i do want to live
debt-free so
um so it starts kind of as a money thing
but like john said it ends up being
about other parts of the relationship
and what happens is when you get married
that stuff just magnifies like it just
becomes
bigger and so
so yeah i mean i do think i think
there's an initial red flag for sure
that you guys just aren't on the same
page with it and especially if there's a
big goal that you want to have and not
just to have that goal for
having a goal sake but because of what
it brings you and that's kind of what
john was saying too right it's bringing
you this piece it's bringing you this
level of control that you want
and if she can't get on board with that
then it's going to be hard to i think
even on those issues of control and
peace with parents and kids in the
future right you could plug in other
issues in marriage
in that same bucket so can i ask you is
gabriel um
how old are y'all
i'm 27 she's 25. okay
um
she's still turning to dad for financial
support at 25.
is that
is that a red flag in your heart and
mind i i think it is um i i
i was trying to convince her to look at
into used cars i would kept showing her
listings so
you know i didn't know how how far i
could push against her dad's uh sort of
plan or wish to sign the car for her so
that was that was a pretty big flag for
me
why three and a half years
i think um and i think this is something
that i
i for the first maybe one or two years
we've just haven't really talked about a
lot about money until i started getting
serious about paying down my loans and
so
i feel like
i slowly started bringing that up um and
i'm constantly talking to to her about
like oh i made a payment to towards my
life okay why are you all married why
aren't you married brother
i think i think this is something that
i was scared to bring up okay
and so i think there is a fear of like
well i don't want to you know get
married and then
um
come to realize that we don't have money
issues but a marriage issue yeah yes and
so let me let this that's the biggest
red flag of them all
is
i i have a i have a fear in my heart
i've got a secret i've got i'm scared of
something
and i'm not i don't feel safe enough to
tell you whether it's because i don't
have the strength or because i'm fearful
of the response that to me is the
biggest red flag if you are going to
join
the rest of your life with somebody else
if you're gonna make other humans with
somebody else
at minimum you've got to be able to have
hard conversations together in a
respectful dignified loving way
and that's where i would start here and
so this whole thing gabriel starts with
you and a pad and a piece of paper
writing down what are the things that
concern you about this woman that you've
been dating for three and a half years
you know her now
something is telling you
i'm still hesitant what is it write
those things down and then have a hard
but
life-giving truthful conversation with
her about this stuff and then let's
again let's go about joining vision yeah
and and obviously
we want the best for you gabriel and we
want well i would love for this
relationship to work right like you want
it to um but i think
john's exactly right like this i think
this is one of the issues is that you
get into this lifelong commitment and
don't really even know what you're
signing up for and i think there's a i i
i think there's a element of that that
is true no matter what i mean as much
pre-made account i think you can do
whatever you can to prepare and nothing
prepares you for marriage than marriage
but the hesitancy that yes that's going
on in your voice right now gabriel and
kind of that back and forth press into
that here here's what you you can never
prepare for the issues
but you can practice
the hard conversations yeah right so if
you can have this little one the way you
drive
when we're dating makes me uncomfortable
and it scares me will you please slow
down when i'm in the car
that may have been a conversation we had
i was dating sheila my response was
absolutely i don't ever want to scare
you yeah and for her she said okay
that's a guy that i can feel safe with
telling my needs to and i was able to
say that's somebody that i value who
will tell me
right you're gonna practice that
[Music]
great
[Music]
we are back at the on the ramsey show
and on the debt-free stage we have lisa
and darren from detroit michigan and i'm
guessing that means you're here to do
your debt-free scream yes sir
congratulations before we get there
going along with the money and marriage
theme quickly what is a pet peeve you
have of each other
oh my yeah
all of them not enough time just one
i think through the debt-free journey
they're gone
oh dude you are the wisest man i've ever
hey that's brother
you're going to come in here and do the
the marriage the next half hour you're
genius that's fantastic all right so
lisa and darren how much did you pay off
147 two forty two thousand just under a
hundred forty two thousand yeah wow
how does that take you
twenty months
twenty months wow how much you making
between like one
twenty
at 120 to 150 and then i run a business
that
we do a for-profit business it makes a
little bit of money
awesome that we don't
what do you guys do for a living i'm an
educator i'm a teacher excellent yeah
and uh i'm self-employed i'd do
landscaping and stuff during the summer
cut grass and
construction during the winter
so you all did this in less than two
years so you guys were living on half
half of what you were making basically
and throwing everything else at the debt
yeah it was a shock we could even do
that yeah absolutely incredible okay so
what what made this happen you guys i
mean 20 months ago what happened um our
daughter got married that was on the
last hour um
we encouraged them to do marriage
counseling
and through the marriage counseling
got us
their their pastor made them do the uh
financial peace university yep and
then they got us in and it wasn't really
easy to get us in i know i want to know
that story it was okay come on
i mean
so for those of you a little inside
baseball your daughter and your
son-in-law did their debt-free scream in
the first hour and they mentioned that
they dragged y'all kicking and screaming
it is hard
for
parents to listen to their kids stick
wisdom for their kids and we all know my
kids are six and 12 and they get to dad
you're not going to believe this you
should do this you should i'm like all
right that's enough for you right yep
how in the world did y'all make that
turn because that's hard it was it was
kind of a roller coaster so in the
beginning darren is very supportive of
everything that our daughter and our son
do um shelby was going to the classes
and
uh
she was trying to encourage us to join
and at first daryn was like i know
everything you need to know about money
like i don't need this and so he started
to go to be supportive and i was i like
had these excuses to not go to the
classes in the beginning um i'm teaching
you know you work longer hours and i've
got report cards to do like you know
every excuse under the sun and i was
more really scared to go because i knew
of our debt or my debt with student
loans and then he was going and then all
of a sudden he drank the kool-aid you
know dave has a way of saucing it up and
he really wanted to go and you know he
was as kind and gentle as he could be
just you know saying this is something
that we can do together and you might
not think that i don't know how much the
debt is but i do know when
what kind of debt was this um most of it
was student loans
wow
142 was mostly yeah yeah yeah more than
half of it graduate school too uh yeah
two master's degrees okay yeah yep and
uh so you guys haven't really talked
about money
not a ton we've been married 30 years
this august okay
yeah so we we did i mean
it's the nodding and grunting phase yeah
kind of we never shared accounts before
this we never did
we didn't do
wow money together yeah yeah and
everything was separate even tithing was
separate um
you know he was he was considered the
one that like he took care of like the
big major expenses you know yeah for the
kids or if we were on a vacation or trip
and it was probably halfway through the
journey before
our teacher bud that came with us
he just kept encouraging me you gotta
do things together and
until you
we've accomplished more in the last
two years than we did in the previous 30
years incredible marriage together it's
incredible wow
so you said you said um and then
some tongue-in-cheek but you're being
serious that
these little petty things
man you all lined up over the last few
years and worked together and a lot of
that petty
pet peeve kind of nonsense is out the
window tell me about that journey
together with your marriage oh my gosh i
think the the stress of finances and
that you know you always hear that you
know money is like a
one of the requests for divorce and
things like that and you don't want to
really accept that but then as you start
paying things off you can let go
you're not as stressed and you don't
have that anxiety over the finances and
then it brings up other things that you
probably need to work on or you didn't
recognize in your marriage so even 30
years in you know those little pet
peevey kind of things or
the lack of communication
you know starts to
starts to make itself present and then
you just kind of work through those
things so the combining the accounts for
me always is just a struggle and it's
it's it's just a symbol of hey of unity
right and and
all that that made everything better
that's what i want to know was it hard
for you guys because after 28 years at
that point in marriage you you had lived
separately with accounts so when you
combined them was that difficult or were
you guys at a place that you were so on
board because there's people listening
right now well you've seen our poster we
did a daughter made as a poster the
poster is ripped to shreds because
i'm halfway through the journey you know
you see all that it's just no i did rip
it so that you didn't rip up the
graph because i was afraid of ripping up
the coloring in because we worked really
hard on that but yeah that was that was
like a frustration part way through but
yeah and the thing i i guess really the
important thing is
is our life and our friendship
and everything
could have been so much better so
so much before
i was willing to share
everything with my wife
except for my money and it's
as you know it's just
i'm embarrassed about it and ashamed of
it now but
but here's the thing
but it's it's better now that's right
awesome that's right and often shame
curls us up in a ball and we don't do
anything and the one powerful move you
made was to take that one step and you
listen to your baby little girl and then
you took another one and then you took
another one and
you were brave right and you were strong
and man i think what you've done i mean
it's generational look i mean you've got
a grandkid over here that's not gonna
ever know these struggles because of the
work you did my man so none of the last
28 years are wasted it's incredible
incredible you two who's your biggest
cheerleaders oh my gosh definitely max
and shelby yeah yeah and it's max not
maximilian but now he's gonna have to go
by maximilian now because oh he gave us
the full name
yeah um no i'm just kidding uh yeah they
were probably our biggest cheerleaders
like we would have these funny
competitions of you know what are you
selling what are you putting up for sale
what are you getting rid of get rid of
the dog like
you know just like little things like
that so there was a lot of a lot of
cheerleading going on how does it feel
oh my gosh
i ca i could sleep yeah
yep i could actually sleep at night
which you didn't even we were talking
about that on the way here that i'm like
you know i just realized that
once it was paid off like i could
actually sleep at night like i wasn't
you know my body's not going to war
every day wow aside from you know hot
flashes but it's different
but besides that like i wasn't like
waking up thinking about that paycheck
to paycheck or
okay well i know he's gonna pay for this
and you know and so what if he goes out
and he buys himself another toy it's not
my money so i wha you know i have no
sale for what he's spending the money on
and you know it's not in my business
what he's doing and he didn't tell me
what to do but you know here i am you
know right now you know bills and paying
them and just doing the
you know trying to be the quote-unquote
submissive wife which was you know and
now you're saying and now you're safe
and connected and your body can finally
totally finally he's incredible
142
thousand dollars in 20 months paid off
making 120 to 150 grand working a couple
of jobs a teacher construction mowing
lawns lisa and darren from detroit
michigan let's hear your debt-free
scream count it down three two one we're
done free
yes
so great
dad hey brother we're gonna give you a
copy of total money makeover so you can
find somebody in your community that you
know that would man this is gonna jump
start their journey and we're gonna give
you a copy of baby steps a millionaire
because now you two are together and
there is
no stopping lisa and darren y'all that's
life's change right there not just money
change life and marriage i don't care
how long you've been married
every day is a day to start over and say
today's gonna be different
i'm talking to you yes to you today can
be different
start now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show i'm john
delonia joined here by rachel cruz and
we're taking your calls on
money retirement life anything and
everything triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to tracy in
montgomery alabama hey tracy what's
going on
good afternoon thank you for taking my
call you bet what can we do
um
my question is is i'm kind of in baby
steps too right now um
as far as getting my debt paid off and i
should have
it paid off hopefully
by
everything that
uh
one payment will be paid off by this
time next year and it will still
probably take me another year to pay off
the loan
um on a horse trailer because i live in
rural alabama but
what it is
um
i'm 50 and
i'm looking at
after this debt is paid off
how to
better
invest as far as like a roth ira or
mutual funds i've got my 401k right now
with work and i'm only investing at 5
and i have a stock purchase program with
my company
and i'm doing two percent of it right
now
and
i want to be able to invest more
you know after my debt is paid off i
don't have a mortgage i actually
uh
my mother-in-law put my name on the deed
for the property and
so i could
pick up the
she didn't want to do the homeowners
insurance on the house so tell me tell
me about your debts here um you said
you're about a year away what kind of
debt do you got how much you got
it's i've got
one more truck payment left and my truck
is used and
i don't plan on getting rid of it tell
me the numbers yeah
um i've got about 14 000 with credit
card
and then i've got 24 000 on the horse
trailer
and what is this
okay 24. what do you make a year
i make 40.
40. and the horse trailer is that for
um
for your job is that what tell me a
little bit about that it's
that's my
hobby my
my kids i guess i call them because i
don't have any children and
my fiancee pretty much husband
um
this was his mother's
and father's place and we got 60 acres
so okay
and it's paid for
so the the place great good for y'all um
i i want to make real clear that place
is not
you have no claim no moment no
not a second not a penny towards that
place until y'all are married
and so um well actually
in alabama because she put my name on
the d she passed away in november did
she put your name on the deed too
yeah
i'm the only one that was on the bead
other than her
so so her blood was not she didn't put
her son on it but she put you on it
that's not messy at all so my
recommendation honestly everybody's
everybody's good with it so it's it's
it's all mutual believe it or not
i believe in a jerry springer moment no
no no it's it's um
our show
like the work that i've done for years
work rachel's done for years where
dave's done for years
is that everybody's got a great idea
until the wheels fall off and what we
deal with all day is when people are
saying uh-oh right but here that's a
whole other call holder show um i'm
gonna rachel i'll let you hop in here
i'm going to recommend sell the horse
trailer yeah no that's not cool and
that's going to make you sad and i'm not
doing that and i know here's the thing i
know you're not going to but i think you
should sell the horse trailer and start
from there well tracy so here's the deal
you're 50 years old right so you know
when you're looking at retirement here
in the next 15 years
um there has to be some
some decisions that you make to up this
do you have anything in retirement i
know you have a 401k at work how much is
in that
uh right now there's about 60 000 in it
and
i'm really not sure
on my
i mean with the way the market's been
in my company it's
my
spot purchase program i have has just
been
really like up and down yeah yeah
okay well you're the which is great that
you have 60 000 in there so
what i want to do is i want you to
actually pause everything else you said
you were doing two percent of the stock
option of the company you're doing a
little bit in the 401k
as of now i want you to pause your 401k
because to be able to get out of this
debt the fastest way possible is to get
as much cash back in your paycheck to
throw at this debt and so by doing this
and by being able to throw off you know
some more money into this credit card
debt it's going to get you it's going to
get you moving so i would i mean i'm
kind of on i'm on john's team on this
one um tracy that's hard but
something like a horse trailer and if
you were making
you know 140 a year this is a different
conversation you're making 40 000 a year
with a 200 with a 24 thousand dollar
thing with wheels and whenever we say a
thing with wheels i don't care if that's
an rv i don't care if that's a trailer i
don't care if that's a car
but you don't want half of your annual
income to be in what we call four sets
of wheels appreciating asset yeah so by
removing that and by throwing as much
money at this credit card that you could
be out of debt in nine months if you if
you paused
paused the retirement
sold the horse trailer got out of that
debt threw more money at this 14 000
credit card debt you could be debt free
and then we can fast forward to say okay
from there building up an emergency fund
going back to your retirement so you're
only pausing for a year in this plan
uh and then throwing as much money as
possible at the retirement but i also
tracy would tell you to go talk to a
smart investor pro
they are
a trusted group of people here at ramsey
solutions that we recommend and all over
america but for them to sit down with
you and do the math because i don't want
you
um here in the next 10 years to
not be funding as much as you should be
so there may be more money you want to
throw at retirement after you're out of
debt you have that emergency yeah i'd go
one step further and i'd even said i
would get the number today and if not
today monday
i would get the
number that
how much those stock options are worth
and i would consider selling single
stock
and paying your debt off um and i know
you think no my company they're doing
great my mom had worked at enron
and it went away right and so we always
want folks to be careful about dumping a
bunch of money into single stock
purchases into their own company this
might be you may have won the lottery
when it comes to luck and you're sitting
on enough stock to get you completely
completely out of debt and then you roll
the rest of that over into your 401 and
now you're off to the races so you go
buy yourself a roth ira and max it out
and you're off to the races there all
right let's take one more quick call
let's go to allison in new orleans hey
allison we're up against the clock so uh
get right to your question
hi john hi rachel
how's it going
i'm doing well thank you and yourself
good good good good all right we're up
against the clock so let's get right to
your question
okay sure can you hear me okay yes ma'am
okay great um last year both of my
parents passed away and we're right in
the middle of having to sell the house
at this point
um i've been following day for about
five years or so i have a fully funded
emergency fund i have about fifty
thousand dollars that i could possibly
use um in an account that's going to be
available pretty soon
in order to buy something and my basic
question right now is
um how to
go from one house to the other so should
i wait until the house is sold i can
actually borrow 40 000 from my
emergency fund and put that with this 50
000 that i'm gonna have and then pay off
if i
have a mortgage i could pay it off with
the money that i get from the house
after we sell it
or i can um i actually saved up about
eleven thousand dollars um to go and
rent something if i needed to
um which would i know mean moving twice
but i'm trying to do this the cheapest
way in the most um
efficient way financially so
so your parents passed away and you were
living in their house so now the house
has to be sold is any is any of the
equity going to be split between kids
like once the house sells are there
other people that are going to be
getting part of this okay so what if the
house sold at market today do you know
how much money you would be receiving
for just your end
um i'm guessing um somewhere upwards
either 125 or high okay i would wait
till the house sells
uh at this point and then when it sells
move out and then move twice and give
yourself a little bit of space put down
a down payment of 10 to 20 with some of
this cash and you have you're in a great
position allison you just throw out a
bunch of numbers of cash you have set
aside it's great i would rent and move
twice i know that's a pain
it may not be the cheapest option but
it's going to be the most peaceful
option and right now your heart needs
some peace i think james and kelly and
the gang and you america will be back
soon on the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsey show where america hangs out
to have a conversation
about your money your life your marriage
everything triple eight eight two five
five two two five i'm john delony joined
here by best selling author and my
brilliant friend rachel cruz and we're
taking your calls on
everything and rachel we got a big event
tonight money and marriage valentine's
day edition
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna save
some marriages
let's hope so john let's hope so
no these this event always is fun this
is our fourth time doing it together and
you know it's two subjects that i think
have a lot of tension points a lot of
things to celebrate and it's just two
big issues to say hey let's come
together in one night
talk about it and
and really walk people through i think
there's you know it's obviously it's fun
and aspirational but we'll give you some
instruction on things like hey start
doing this tonight here's like some
small things you can start to change
in your marriage some small things you
can start to change about your money
that really will lead to big results in
your life that's what we want for you
guys we don't want you to live in
a place where you don't have peace
and we want to be able to help you say
hey here are some of the best practices
in these two areas yeah and so man we're
going to be talking about sex we're
going to be talking about money we're
talking about fear we're gonna be
talking about goals like how to get on
the same page together we'll be talking
about all of it right so we'd love to
have you join us if you're a ramsay plus
member it's free
it's free go to your rm2 plus and log in
and it will be yours to stream if you
want to buy tickets they're 30 bucks not
a piece but for both of you right uh go
to ra money uh go to ramseysolutions.com
events
and pick up your tickets we will look
forward to seeing you there it's going
to be a blast um and then the last hour
we talked about pet peeves of
spouses yes
which is great and i want to find out
who's next
let's go to julian hartford uh and see
let's ask her hey julie
hi how are we doing
uh hey
hanging in there are you married
for uh it's gonna be 23 years on the
28th of this month
you're a perfect person to ask what is
your biggest pet peeve
um
of your partner there what's your
biggest pet peeve
uh i would say he likes to um
uh
instead of getting a floss to clean his
teeth he kind of like sucks on like like
this weird sound that he does
it drives me much it just drives me much
oh hey julie talking to your phone real
quick so that's so good weird mouth
noises are usually at the top of the
list if if he had to name one pet peeve
of yours that you do what would it be
sloshing too much
flossing too much that's
great teeth ridiculous pet peeve julie
it's like when you are at a job
interview and they say what's your
biggest weakness you say i just care so
much i just work too hard work too hard
that's the problem well done julia floss
too much all right so that was our
little detour what's up how can we help
okay well i mean
oh god um so i
i
i've been to i graduated from uh
financial peace university i actually
spoke to rachel's dad um
dave uh a few
years ago just before it coded so we
didn't really get to graduate because
kovic came into play
but um
you know i had a lot of debts
um over 50 000 worth of debt and um just
a lot of stuff going on
today i can say that all the debt is
paid off nice julie and
and all i owe is um
you know my mortgage pay off my mortgage
which i'm working on it with gazelle
intensity congrats you are using a lot
of eye language is your husband involved
in this
no
oh
okay
she's backing up it's those
rumors it's all that flossing julie if
you'll quit flossing he'll partner with
you
i mean maybe i won't say um entirely
not as much as i would like him to okay
that's hard so what's your question
so my question is you know
how should i
i mean i try to how should i approach
them i might be doing something wrong um
i i we usually we have about i mean like
35 bills each month you know we're both
entrepreneurs
i've been
a little bit more stable than he is
um
and i've just been pretty much paying
all the bills
um and i i just asked him if you can
just pay at least four bills um which is
like help us to buy the food we have
four children um help us to pay you know
the cell phone bill uh maybe some
utility and just to you know maintain
the houses
and it's just it's just a fight with him
all the time um i just had a shutoff
notice the other day for my light
um
because he just didn't pay it last month
and it just
you know it just got a lot so here's the
thing julie
you all have been married legally for
23 years
but y'all are
less married and more co-managers
because the way you're talking about him
is the way when i used to
lead employees they would talk to me
about a co-worker
not about their life partner the person
they pledged there and
the person they said before god and
their friends i'm going to serve this
person for the rest of my life and vice
versa
everything is mine and i and he didn't
there is never been a we in this
conversation and so often when folks get
excited about fpu
they get excited about a plan they're
going to get debt free
and it's about me
and it's about
how i feel
he's got to be bought into a
much bigger vision but your y'all's
challenges is much deeper than money
money's the big flashing neon sign for
y'all but y'all are living separate
lives because i want to make sure julie
that that i'm clear that it's not just
a tactical
he's not
paying a bill because i want him to help
with it underneath all of that he's just
not on board would you say like do you
feel emotionally supported in the money
process
not at all like i'm financially
drained
so here's so here's the difference julie
here's what i'll say because there are
couples we talk to who are on the same
page with money but one is just
naturally
more detailed right there's a
personality difference there too that's
winston and i i don't pay any bills if
it was up to me to pay a bill we would
not our water would be shut off because
i would forget like i just i'm terrible
at details so winston takes care of it
but we're a team on it though like we we
know what's going on we i support him um
he supports me like there is a team
aspect right so the tactical side of who
pays and punches the the buttons to pay
the bills
that could be yeah sure one spouse and
that's fine
but the problem here is all the
underneath the stuff right it's coming
out as yeah he's not choosing to help me
do the tactical stuff but really it's
that emotional stuff underneath you guys
are just not a team you're not you're
not there and that's that's what you
want to hit on right so here's here's
where we start here's where we start
julie
you all go out and i want you to look
him in the eye and hold his hands and
tell him
i'm sorry for trying to have done this
marriage all by myself
we're 23 years in we got another 30 or
40 or 50 to go i want us to connect
and start today and here's the vision
that i would love for us to see and once
you'll have a vision conversation the
tactics will follow juggle i get on the
same page
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast
you've outgrown your financial and
accounting software the faster you grow
the more likely you are to lose control
of the numbers and here's the reality if
you don't know your numbers you don't
know your business that's why we use
netsuite by oracle the number one cloud
financial system over 28 000 companies
use netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
well money is one of the biggest sources
of stress for married couples and that's
why it's really important to learn the
right way on how to manage your money
and build wealth so this valentine's day
instead of just an ordinary date night
put an end to money stress in your
marriage or you can even bless a couple
who's about to tie the knots so our
valentine's day sale includes all kinds
of gifts gifts that will strengthen your
marriage
and they're as much as 83
off so
it starts with the brand new questions
for humans conversations for couples
john deloney that's yours they're so fun
we use them like even in our team like
we use the friends ones
oh it's so good so you'll get these 15
or 55 conversation starters that will
help you connect with your spouse you
guys will laugh together and really just
have quality time and
uh or you can gift our bundle as the
wedding gift pack to give to newlyweds
or engaged couples to help them start
off on the right foot so these are not
just ordinary valentine's day gifts they
actually have the potential to
completely change your marriage so go to
the online store at ramsey solutions and
shop the valentine's day sale and get 83
percent off before it ends i love it all
right find out why yourself
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window covering you'll get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code ramsey to get the
best deal
so today's question comes from amy in
south dakota
my husband drank the dave ramsey
kool-aid about 10 years ago we worked
extremely hard budgeting and paying off
debt however every time we get close to
paying off his credit card something
comes up that he has to buy most
recently he bought a very expensive
rifle for hunting this purchase bothered
me but it did
but he knew
he would hold it against me if i didn't
let him get the gun
man
it was more not that the system would
never happen in either of our houses are
you about ready for this though it's
more than we'd spend on a family trip
and he'll use it one week in a year for
deer hunting with his friends how do i
let this go and get back on track so so
there was a lot there's a lot of layers
to that one for me i was like ah
not that that's probably happened in
your house or my house for sure
um here's the thing
this call
first your husband didn't drink the
ramsay kool-aid he died he read it and
thought it was a good idea and thought
it sounded fun
um and was ish right kind of leaned into
it a little bit
at the end here she writes it was more
than we would ever spend on a family
trip he'll use it one weekend a year so
she's trying to
turn this into a math problem that he
should have known how expensive it was
relative to our vacations relative to it
this is not a math problem
this is a woman who feels betrayed
because her husband's acting like a
child and they agreed
together on a vision and he refuses to
do it to do it and so this is a betrayal
so
amy how can you let this go and help us
get back on track
in my house this would not be something
we'd just let go of this would be
something that we sat down and said no i
can't believe you bought that rifle
it would be i can't believe you betrayed
our vision that we agreed together where
we were headed and that's a totally
different conversation right absolutely
yep and it's and it's hurtful i mean and
amy you lose trust in it uh there's
frustration there all of it and i just
want to know on his side
um
you know ask him questions of like you
know did you did you consider
what was happening like what like you
know mean like get to know understand
deeper
him and his motivations and why he's
thinking the way he is
she has a line here
i knew he would hold it against me if i
didn't let him get this
listen
i'm talking to husbands here but i'm
talking to everybody if you and your
spouse agree on a thing
and one of you has the courage when
you're having a bad day right we all do
we all buy that thing you're like i fell
off the wagon
if one of your if your spouse has the
courage to call you out on it
never
be one of those morons who holds it
against them
you let me get my gun
shut up you're on the same page that's
you know who does that children
elementary school ones in fact not even
middle school kids don't even act like
this
don't be like that if somebody has the
courage to say hey we that's a 4 500 gun
that's not a part of our vision our
vision was to be debt free to change our
family legacy to pay off our house don't
do that
say thank you for holding me accountable
and i know it hurts and it stinks and i
really really really want that
and now it's not the time so how do
people work towards that john because
that's just uh to me that's maturity yep
that's a level of maturity of growing up
and being a grown up
so it's someone that says okay that
sounds great but my need your correction
is to go there my knee just correction
is to be like kind of spite how do you
start to work
through that i wish it was more
complicated and it's actually pretty
simple and the magic word is practice
the magic words practice we've
fallen into this trap that we believe
every interaction
is all or nothing and it's just not and
so decide i'm going to change my
identity i'm not going to be a husband
who says this is my money i could bow
down i'm not going to be like that i'm
going to be a husband that serves my
wife make sure that our home is taken
care of and that we're all in
partnership on this we're co-creating
this vision and we're living it out
and when you feel yourself getting angry
when you feel yourself
ready to snap and even if you do you
stop and you say i'm sorry about that
you circle back and say i acted like a
fourth grader back there
i'm working hard and i'm sorry um here's
what i meant to say here's what i should
have said and we're going to keep
practicing and if you will practice over
time your body quits reacting like that
yeah because it knows it doesn't help
anything yep right it's good and some
humility too
oh sorry amy this gets me riled up man
sorry amy it gets me riled up and to the
person out there who says oh yeah that
sounds cute dude um
i'm just gonna go tell him and have this
conversation
get the money in marriage live stream
tonight we talk about this exact thing
on how to do that tonight all right
let's go to
leslie in
the lbc in long beach what's up leslie
hi thank you for taking my call you bet
what's up how can we help
i was calling um
i'm a single mother with a
three-year-old son hey uh leslie leslie
can you speak directly into the phone
speak loud and proud and bold
uh
yeah so i was calling because i'm having
trouble starting
i don't i feel like every time i start
something happens um
so i feel like i can't
never get past
step one um
so like recently um
i have
back in 2020 i signed a car for my son's
dad
and unfortunately um the first day of
the year um
it got
totaled um someone lived on fire so that
kind of put me on a big liability so
that kind of backtracked me um so i just
feel like something like that always
kind of like prevents me from like
saving like because i'd have to take out
savings and then cover like emergency
costs like that and
i just have like trouble like kind of
starting i guess advice like what to do
or
i just i don't know where to begin yeah
um well leslie i hear it in your voice
you have a lot going on you're a single
mom of a three-year-old which is a lot a
lot of work
that you're doing so number one i just
want to commend you for even having the
courage to start this to start something
new
um because i know it can be scary and
something different and you're going at
it by yourself right now um so number
one just know you can do it
um thank you number two i would say on a
more tactical level
i want you to
are you are you liv are you doing a
budget like do you know exactly where
every single dollar of your paycheck is
going
yes um but i feel like even um you know
i kind of got a raise towards the end of
the year like i felt like
uh how you guys feel like my shovel is
not enough yeah how much do you make to
me even
um
like take home
uh 2800
in a month in a month okay in long beach
which is very expensive place to live
right
yes
uh and how much debt do you have
um so in total 22
000 17 is my car which that's the hard
part is mainly that big chunk and then
it's like a thousand seven hundred and
credit card and then the rest is kind of
like closed yet that you know it's
closed off but i still need to take care
of yeah
okay so leslie but for so for your
income yeah i mean it's not you don't
have a huge shovel i mean
i think before
i mean after taxes i mean you're taking
home about you know 25 26 000. so i
really really want you to up that income
leslie um and that means maybe even
shifting careers because once you can
get this income and even look i want you
to be looking at selling that car 17 000
is a big a lot of car for you
sell it get a junker and that's going to
alleviate a lot right there but getting
on that budget and knowing exactly where
your money's going looking at selling
the car and looking at a different
career i think is going to help a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
on the line we have larry and shannon
from saint cloud minnesota
and it says on my screen here you are
debt free
yes you are
congratulations good credits you guys
how much have you paid off
uh we paid off 123 000. whoa
how long did that take you
two years and seven months wow
what were you making what was your
income
um we started off around 140 and by the
end of the year it was about 175.
nice what do you guys do for a living
i was working in healthcare running
assisted living facilities and recently
just changed to human resources
awesome i'm a physical plant supervisor
for
one of the state of minnesota campuses
very cool what was this debt
it was our house whoa
paid off your house we did
congratulations y'all are official
weirdos that's incredible how much is
this how much is this house worth
um right now it's looking about 260 270.
oh amazing how old are you guys
um we just had birthdays after we paid
our house off but i was 31 when we paid
it off i was 34. oh wow
not even 35 early 30s with a paid off
house
so what happened two and a half years
ago that you said enough is enough let's
do this
well after we got married we started
looking for houses and going through the
mortgage process thinking of
a 30-year mortgage and being almost 60
when i paid off a house that freaked me
out so
we started looking at options i didn't
even want to buy a house at that point
so i'd heard of dave ramsey before i
hadn't really listened to him or
anything
but i started listening to the podcast
and hearing about the 15-year fix and
that alone sounded way better than 30
years so
we then crunched the numbers and
realized we could probably even pay off
in five years
once we started going um it was pretty
easy and we were paying it off pretty
quickly so we changed our goal to three
years and then two years seven months
later we were done oh my wow
here's what i love about it it's like
you just did it you know there's a lot
of people like um but we have this we
have this
you guys just were like we're just gonna
do it but we're just gonna do it i mean
and that's pretty intense like we even
tell people you can kind of let your
foot off the you know the gas some baby
steps four five and six but man y'all
just y'all did it i mean y'all threw so
much money at this mortgage that's
incredible
yeah i'm just looking at the math here
y'all
y'all basically lived on half of your
income for a couple years right
yeah yeah we did we pretty much uh lived
off of hers and took
well yeah lived up for hers and threw
mine at the house pretty much that's so
great amazing so how'd you find out
about this weird group of people that
does all this
um well i don't know my family had
listened to i mean had talked about dave
ramsey forever and um once we started
dating
you know larry had some debt i didn't
and we kind of talked about that and
i just said like i don't want to really
marry into a lot of debt or anything so
then he bought the total money makeover
and
started reading that right away and
paying off his debt and then we kind of
um didn't really i don't really listen
to it or anything after that but then
once we started doing the house i think
we really started listening to the
podcast a lot more and
going back to what what he learned in
the book and everything
that's amazing so good so um what did
you guys do to get out of debt i see
here you you got quite a bit of big
raise you got 35 000 raise over the
course of two and a half years what were
y'all doing were you hustling side
hustling cutting what was going on there
it was just um raises at work and then
um bonuses and then um with covid
hitting actually you know working in
healthcare we got
um you know like hazard pay covert pay
kind of a thing so we actually got paid
more um for working during covid so and
then we also couldn't really go on the
vacations that we usually would go on
and everything so it was kind of
covet happened at a right time for us to
not be able to do anything
i've heard that a lot from a lot of
people they're like it canceled all my
plans so i saved all my money
that's amazing so what was the hardest
part for you guys because you guys are
you know you're in your early 30s people
are just living their lives
but you guys buckled down and paid off
your house so like what was what was
hard about that because that that's
tough you lived on half your income
yeah reducing spending um
by putting some things on the back
burner
such as since we bought our house we
didn't have air conditioning
and you know having people over the
summertime it gets really hot and humid
and so you go take trips you know to
river or something go swimming instead
of using the air conditioning that's so
great restoring
18 years and
also we put off remodeling our kitchen
too so yeah
hey man linoleum is not as bad as as a
house payment so good for you guys well
now you don't have a house payment you
can throw it all your kitchen remodel
you got money so who thought you were
crazy
what's that y'all had to have people in
your lives that just thought y'all were
bonkers
yeah yeah i have friends that tell me
that
yeah there's a lot of geniuses walking
around college campuses i used to be one
of them that have all kinds of opinions
and ideas and here you were just slowly
grinding away in the shadows right
yeah
[Music]
and you're around a lot of fancy doctors
who have it all figured out and here you
were just grinding and grinding and
grinding
so who are your biggest cheerleaders
well for me i would say
the biggest one is my wife because like
she said she didn't want to have any
debt so
she was cheering more than more and
harder than anyone
yeah and i think my parents they knew we
were you know paying it off and kind of
kind of you know kept cheering us on
throughout the throughout the process
that's awesome you guys how does it feel
to not have a house payment
it feels good that was my first loan and
last loan that i will ever take part in
feels good to be done
so if somebody came and just ran into
you out there in the frozen tundra of st
cloud and said
what's the key to getting out of debt
what's the one thing you would tell them
um for me i would say that you have to
want it like for i guess money is
freedom you know freedom to leave a job
you don't like freedom to retire early
and you have to want your freedom more
than you want you know a bunch of stuff
that you don't even need
it's good that's a good word
for me i said discipline having an end
goal and having the mindset that
nothing's gonna
stop us from doing it
so have you had that
paycheck deposit or two paychecks
deposit and there's no mortgage has that
happened yet
oh yeah oh yeah how does that feel we've
been paid off for a while yeah it feels
good our bank account just keeps
rising instead of you know staying
stagnant with us paying off the house
every month
oh that's so incredible so what are you
gonna do now you you don't owe anybody
anything what are you gonna do now
we're gonna do our kitchen remodel we're
gonna fix up his car we're gonna go back
on vacations and do whatever we want
i love that line we're gonna do whatever
we want well
larry and shannon we have a copy of the
legacy journey for you we also have a
copy of
baby steps millionaires because that is
y'all's next step there's no stopping
this couple we're also gonna send you a
copy of the total money makeover and we
want you to give that to somebody that
is in your life that you know
they just need a gentle nudge so here
they go we're gonna send them on their
way so we're gonna give you that so you
can pass that along
all right larry and shannon from saint
cloud minnesota
making a paid off 123 000
in two years and seven months making 140
grand to about 175 grand
and they paid off their house
so exciting count it down let's hear a
debt free screen
three two one
[Music]
oh that's amazing
what's up what's amazing
is that she said
i'm not marrying anybody in debt and
he's like i'll fix that i know i'm right
on that
hey man i saw some of the videos i had
up on the screen she's wearing camo and
carhartt that's a special woman and he
said i'm not gonna let this one go
not gonna let this one go
keeping her around i'm gonna keep her
around i'll pay it off whatever it takes
i'll keep the stuff paid off
and i love like you mentioned it
they just decided this is we're done
with this when you wanna you gotta you
gotta want it and like and their
intensity in that i'm like that's what
that's a part of it right this whole
emotional side of your money it's real
yes and this mindset that when you put
when you say something
do it and
i don't want people to miss this the
last few years has been hard on
everybody right and for some folks for
millions and millions it buried them and
it's been hard to move it's hard to
breathe and for others they said we're
gonna take a moment while the world is
on pause and we're going to get so far
ahead that we can knit that you know
what i mean that we can never get chased
down again so if you're one of those
couples one of those people that have
been buried low it's time to stand up
the sun's coming out let's get after it
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the scripture of today is second
corinthians 9
10.
now he who supplies seed to the sower
and bread for food will also supply and
increase your store of seed and will
enlarge the harvest of your
righteousness
robert louis stevenson said don't judge
each day by the harvest you reap but by
the seeds that you plant
i love robert louis stevenson all right
let's go out to alyssa in wisconsin hey
alyssa what's happening
hi thank you i'm a big fan of the show
and i really appreciate what you guys do
thank you so much we're a huge fan of
you thank you so much for calling what's
up how can we help
i'm wondering if it is better to sell a
vehicle while i still owe money on it or
wait a few months until i can pay it off
and then sell it to downgrade in vehicle
great question okay so how much do you
owe on the car
nine thousand five hundred nine thousand
and how much do you make in a year
uh together my husband and i make about
130 000 with a lot of his overtime okay
and is that the only debt you guys have
yes we've already paid off six figures
and this is the last of it wow alyssa
congrats
um yeah i would sell i i'm sorry i would
i would pay this off you guys have
plenty of income go ahead and just knock
it out and then yeah if you want to
downgrade from there um then you
absolutely can it's just it's a great
market right now for used cars so you
can get a lot for it but i would love it
paid for so that way you guys can just
yeah you're all right debt free and then
when you're debt free do you want it do
you want to downgrade at that point
though because the car isn't really a
big issue for you you just don't need it
or what's the point to downgrade for you
um so
he's burnt out in his current career and
wants to trade careers and the training
in the new career is very expensive
okay
so we're we're wanting to pile up money
as quick as possible for him to be able
to get out of his current work situation
i gotcha okay
um
and how much is the car worth now
about 21 000
okay
because i'm just trying to do the math i
mean in a sense i mean if there's
something that you guys want to do now
and use that cash towards it
um
you could sell it obviously
pay it off get a new car all that i
almost would just i would just pay it
off and then go
tell me about this burnout what does
what do you mean with your husband
um he's in law enforcement
and it's been pretty tough on him
the candle's been burning low so i asked
him to read from paycheck to purpose and
he's very convicted in becoming a pilot
and flight training is very expensive so
yeah we're hoping to build up 80 000 as
quickly as possible for him to get out
gotcha okay
so here's after an emergency fund yes
yes yes yes
so when somebody
i would love for the two of you and i'm
speaking from somebody who's i've got
connections law enforcement i've shared
a home with law enforcement
that's my
my heritage i grew up with that crew
i've worked with that crew
um
i would love for the two of you
to go meet with a
pastor or a marriage counselor not
because you are broken in fact the
opposite sometimes the best time to go
talk to somebody about future planning
just having a neutral third party and
here's why
i
when people say i need to sell my car
that to me says there's an imminent this
thing's on fire and i'm throwing every
ounce of water i'm throwing the water
bottles at this thing to try to put the
fire out
and i want to know i want him to be able
to have a space where he can speak
openly and say no i can do two more
years or once i put a period at the end
of the sentence when i when i say okay
in 24 months i'm going to retire
i can take 24 months it's often the
unknown i can't keep doing this feels
like forever versus i've got an exit
strategy and that's different then we
need to sell the car we need to sell the
dog let's see if one of our kids
wouldn't mind we like we're going to
sell the couches right
and everything feels on fire when we
have that level of emotion that level of
stress but i want to know how imminent
this burnout is and i'll tell you
i have been in burnout where it's time
for me to go now i've been there
and i've also been in i can't keep doing
this long term which is ended up being a
two or three year transition
so we did actually have that exact
conversation
and i did project about two years the
emergency fund and the tuition and he's
saying that he can't handle two years
okay
so he's out huh
yeah okay so here's the other thing
you've done then you've boxed yourself
into
it's either this
or it's that
my recommendation would be that he
leaves and gets a job at home depot gets
a job paying the bills
and i mean serious a job that's gonna
let him heal and that's gonna let him
kind of get his feet back underneath him
and i want him to go talk to somebody
because that job he's been in is brutal
and
uh and and also know this my mom was the
wife of a police officer for many many
years you wear this too right do you
have someone to talk to
yes okay excellent so i'd love to see
just a gap
because this pilot training it sounds
great it's what i want to do next and
you're such a great partner and you want
to support him fully it's 80 000
yep is that fair
yep so what we often do when we get
scared we get nervous or we have to jump
which i trust him if he says i gotta go
now then you gotta go now we box
ourselves into well then if we gotta go
now it has to be eighty thousand dollars
and i would challenge that assumption
can we wait two years working a minimum
wage job we'll tighten up you all done
such a killer job getting out of debt
yeah really to set you up for this
moment for when we need to make some
major life changes and i'd love to see
y'all do it that way slow down a little
bit
and thank you for your service thank you
for being a wife that walks alongside
him during this mess and we wish you all
the best on the new journey so great
thank you so much
absolutely and yeah john you're exactly
right because that the urgency
limits all your choices yeah when you're
urgent
you jump just to you know it's just like
this one thing and he's running into
something he wants right to be a pilot
all that so i think i
totally agree with that advice
take a breath and you're coming off yes
like you guys said though it's a line of
work that's very difficult i mean it's
been unbelievable so i mean it's not
like he was an accountant and he you
know not that accounts don't have stress
but it's a totally different situation
there and so
yes the emotions i'm sure are very high
um
and kind of just take a beat take a beat
and um
man can i just take a second so excited
that the new book is out yeah pre-sale
is out and we talk about this exact
thing in the book on your past change
your future it is directly the pre-sale
is out right now it's about that
about how do you take ownership of i've
got to make a move now or i'm not okay
now whether that's in work or in your
marriage or in your home or with your
kids or whatever i've got life history
worth of trauma whatever's going on now
i gotta stop
grieve that and then i gotta figure out
what's next right and we have a million
books out there on pieces of this and
some of them are complicated some of the
mess this is a book that i wrote
specifically for everybody that we can
all understand a mental health book a
relationship book a what to do next book
that's not complicated full of theories
and nonsense it's just a simple book
that's gonna help somebody walk through
that just like this crew so it lists us
down the line and i'm gonna send you a
free copy of this book and um get you
and your husband on your way to your to
whatever comes next so good and i even
love that title of owning your past like
there's a level of you and even their
story right yeah of sitting in what
happened like you know yeah it's been
hard what's happened yes and and to be
in that and i feel like we can live in
this world we just run to the next thing
that feels like it masks it right it
makes it feel better but it's like this
beach ball that's going to it's going to
keep coming up i love that it will keep
coming back and sometimes this the
ultimate destination isn't the tomorrow
destination right there's going to be a
season of rest there's going to be a
season of reflection or pausing or just
working at starbucks or home depot for a
while until we can save up the money to
do the next big thing that's right
that's right
well i and i'm so excited about this
book drone it comes out when when's like
the actual actual comes out in april if
you buy it now it comes with a man
better help stepped up comes with a free
month of counseling which is huge
hundreds of dollars worth of stuff free
auto book all kind of stuff so you can
pre-order today at ramseysolutions.com
and uh it's very very cool well rachel i
look forward to seeing you here in just
a few minutes when we head over to the
money and marriage event tonight join us
money and marriage tonight go to
ramseysolutions.com events like to thank
james childs kelly daniel and the gang
even connor back there
he just looped all y'all together
grouped you all together that's right
america we're grateful for you be kind
to one another and we will see you soon
on the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you